das menschliche gehirn zu verbessern das
ist die grundidee von ihrem us firma
neuerlich elektronische geräte sollen
direkt mit unserem gehirn verbunden
werden und zwar mit hilfe implantierter
chips im irren die bits und bytes in
gedanken über setzen können und
umgekehrt langfristig gesehen plant
ihren masken damit die menschheit zu
retten denn mit einer mensch maschine
schnittstelle im gehirn während wir in
der lage eine möglicherweise
zerstörerische super intelligenz zu
kontrollieren jetzt die details zu ihnen
us-plänen und welches ziel er damit
verfolgt rix umsatz sinken
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ja nichts herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für den themenvorschlag von
petra niedermeier auf telegramm einen
mast ankündigungen sind nicht ohne schon
2020 möchte der unternehmer der unter
anderem auch die beiden firmen space ex
und tesla führt mit den entwicklungen
von eurer linken die klinische phase
gehen dann also sollen erste studien mit
motorisch eingeschränkten personen
staaten querschnittsgelähmte könnten
dann mit elektroden und sensoren ihr
handy bedienen und das einzig und allein
durch ihre gedanken kraft aber von vorne
im märz 2017 hatte mastjahr das erste
mal in der öffentlichkeit über die pläne
von neuling gesprochen und damit für
aufsehen gesorgt denn ihnen maßgabe dass
langfristig nicht nur auf kranke
menschen wie etwa dürren schlags
patienten abgesehen mit neuerer link wir
ihnen was die menschheit retten wenn
durch eine mensch maschine schnittstelle
im gehirn möchte er eine drohende
apokalypse durch eine künstliche
intelligenz vermeiden maske wird nicht
müde zu betonen dass im laufe der
evolution immer wieder mal die weniger
intelligente spezies durch die
intelligenten verdrängt worden ist nur
wenn der mensch mit maschinen
verschmilzt und dadurch klüger schneller
und produktiver wird werden wir mast
vorstellungen zufolge nicht von einer
potenziell zerstörerischen super
künstlichen intelligenz abgehängt und
dafür investiert der unternehmer
ordentliches heißt dass er seit 2016
bereits 100 millionen dollar in dieses
unternehmen investiert hat derzeit sind
es 100 mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen
die daran arbeiten elektronische geräte
direkt mit unserem gehirn
verbinden und zwar mit hilfe
implantierter chips im hirn die bits und
bytes in gedanken über setzen können und
umgekehrt dafür soll ein sensor ins
menschliche gehirn implantiert werden
denn nur wenige millimeter großes dieser
soll über fäden mit elektroden verbunden
sein die dann wiederum die nervenzellen
kontaktieren der sensor wird über
bluetooth gesteuert sein empfänger wird
hinter dem ohr befestigt und über eine
app die auf dem smartphone läuft
gesteuert die elektroden stimulieren
nicht nur die nervenzellen durch
elektrische impulse sondern messen auch
die aktivität der neuronen bei der
aktuellen präsentation in san francisco
berichtete maske von den neuesten
entwicklungen beispielsweise vom
flexiblen fäden die dünner sein sollen
als das menschliche haar
somit würde das verletzungsrisiko für
das menschliche gehirn im vergleich zu
anderen mensch maschine schnittstellen
enorm gesenkt zudem seien diese neuen
entwicklungen auch in der lage deutlich
mehr daten zu transportieren
das menschliche gehirn wäre somit also
mit einem computer verbunden und wir
menschen könnten allein mit der kraft
der gedanken kommunizieren künstliche
intelligenzen k s könnten so zu unseren
kollegen beziehungsweise nachbarn werden
muss große vision ist es dass wir diese
verstehen und mit ihnen agieren er
erhofft sich dass wir und so unseren
lebensraum mit der ki teilen können und
sie uns nicht gefährlich wird denn ein
großes problem ist dass wir bei ki
anwendungen in den meisten fällen nur
über den input der ki bescheid wissen
was drinnen passiert ist weitgehend
unbekannt weil sie jetzt alles
funktioniert würde es die welt wie wir
sie kennen komplett umkrempeln
beispielsweise die interaktion zwischen
uns menschen und computern anstatt eine
mail zu stoppen würde es ausreichen
einfach kurz an den gewünschten inhalt
zu denken
der computer verwandelt unsere gedanken
dann in den entsprechenden text zudem
hätten wir zugriff auf die gedanken und
erfahrungen anderer menschen so könnten
wir also problemlos die erfahrung von
anderen erleben zum beispiel die eines
prominenten das entwicklerteam von
neuling hat eine art app store für unser
gehirn als vision in dem man sich dann
ganz einfach neue sprachen oder
beispielsweise die fähigkeit ballett zu
tanzen ins gehirn laden kann
so würden wir menschen dann in
verbindung mit computern zu einer super
gau
doch auch die kommunikation zwischen den
menschen untereinander würde
revolutioniert werden denn diese könnten
direkt zwischen gehirn und gehirn laufen
ohne datenverlust oder verzögerung weder
unser mund noch unsere sprache wären
dann mehr notwendig um komplexe inhalte
an andere zu vermitteln auch viele
missverständnisse die durch das bloße
hören von informationen entstehen würden
so von jetzt auf gleich beseitigt werden
doch nicht nur das
euro liegen soll nach den plänen von
elenas zudem auch noch einen roboter
entwickelt der die dafür benötigten
operationen durch wird dieser könnte
dann also die sensoren ins menschliche
gehirn implantieren und das soll dann zu
einer standardmäßigen routine op werden
ähnlich wie heutzutage schon die augen
mit hilfe eines lesers operiert werden
dazu matthew matt nagel neurochirurg von
eurer link letztendlich soll die
operation so einfach sein wie lasik also
roboter augen-op es eine vorstellung die
wirklich nach science-fiction pur klingt
und so gibt es nicht wenige fachleute
die annelen max vision zweifeln viele
fragen sind offen für die technik jemals
zuverlässig funktionieren und was sagen
die gemessenen elektrischen signale
überhaupt aus doch bei aller skepsis
auch wenn das menschliche gehirn super
komplex ist funktioniert es doch im
grunde ähnlich wie einen computer
nämlich mithilfe nein sah und nun also
den binärcode eine eins steht für die
aktion einer nervenzelle die null steht
für den ruhezustand doch der große
unterschied zu computern nervenzellen
verändern sich permanent sie ordnen sich
für kurze oder lange zeit an
so können wir uns immer mehr wissen
einbringen ist aber auch wieder
vergessen oder verändern
durch das so genannte machine learning
kann auch ein computer dazu lernen aber
wenn er dinge einmal kann oder weiß gibt
es keine möglichkeit das abzustufen oder
abzuschwächen
allerdings könnte er wiederum auch die
computersprache des gehirns lernen ein
großes problem das sagen liegt auch in
der speicherkapazität der
computersysteme denn selbst
supercomputer sind derzeit lediglich in
der lage
wenige sekunden der aktivität des
menschlichen gehirns aufzuzeichnen
feststehen aber auch massa hat eine
menge hochkarätige experten und
expertinnen am start angefangen bei sich
selbst oft auch als der da vinci unserer
zeit bezeichnet und wohl unbestritten
einer der besten ingenieure weltweit er
selbst ist sich sicher dass schon ende
des kommenden jahres also 2020 die erste
klinische studie an den start gehen darf
das hat man jetzt in der aktuellen
präsentation verkündet dann könnte sein
system das erste mal implantiert worden
seien eine herausforderung die mit
neuerer link allerdings noch bewältigen
muss ist die genehmigung durch die
behörden verantwortlich ist die
us-arzneimittelbehörde fde ein prozess
der nach worten von ihnen muss selbst
sehr langwierig werden könnte
der neue chef sagt aber auch ganz offen
dass er mit seiner präsentation vor
allem auch darauf abgezielt hatte neue
talente für sein vorhaben anzulocken
da können wir unser gehirn hecken diese
frage beantwortet dr watson dafür hier
anklicken anschauen und doktor watson
abonnieren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran